all right we have an absolutely huge
blockbuster story based on a report from
the house oversight committee which uh
alleges
to have uncovered evidence that donald
trump received millions of dollars from
foreign governments during his
presidency
hid debts
uh concealed losses and we're going to
look at the details of what's alleged
this is sort of like another shoe
dropping as we expected the shoes to
drop after donald trump's presidency
ended
and this might actually explain why
trump put out the statement telling
republican voters don't vote in 2022 and
2024 which we covered earlier to draw
attention away from this report and to
to some degree it worked
as of this morning if you looked on
reddit on the politics subreddit
the trump telling republicans not to
vote story had 70 000 up votes
trump's major ethics violations had 4
000 upvotes so it quite literally is
working now both are real stories
but if the idea was to obfuscate
uh it it is working in a sense so let's
look at this the house committee on
oversight and reform
committee uncovers evidence that trump
concealed millions in losses
hid debts and received millions from
foreign governments at trump hotel look
at this
um
let's actually go skip to the second
part
the document provided by gsa documents
raise new and troubling questions about
trump's lease with gsa and the agency's
ability to manage the former president's
conflicts of interest during his term in
office when he was effectively on both
sides of the contract as landlord and
tenant
specifically the committee found that
president trump provided misleading
information about the financial
situation of the trump hotel and his
financial disclosures received
undisclosed preferential treatment from
a foreign bank on a 170 million dollar
loan to the hotel that the president
personally guaranteed
millions of dollars in emoluments from
foreign governments without providing an
accounting of the money's source or
purpose
concealed hundreds of millions of
dollars in debts from gsa when bidding
on the old post office building lease
and made it impossible for gsa to
properly enforce the leases conflict of
interest restrictions by engaging in
opaque transactions with other
affiliated entities as discussed in this
letter this new evidence raises many
questions that require further
investigation and action by the
committee
this is
a crazy amount of alleged wrongdoing and
unethical behavior
it it it is stunning the degree to which
this was taking place which we knew
this wasn't necessarily we knew this was
going on we knew it wasn't being
investigated seriously enough it was
obvious that this was going on he was
never he never took care of all of those
those conflicts of interest it's
absolutely wild uh a few okay so the
documents show look at the specifics
here
former president trump reported massive
revenues at the trump hotel
concealing that the hotel suffered 70
million dollars in net losses on his
federally mandated financial disclosures
trump reported that the hotel earned him
over 150 million in revenue during his
time in office but the records obtained
show it actually incurred losses of 70
million leading trump's holding company
to inject at least 24 million into the
struggling hotel by filing misleading
public disclosures trump exaggerated the
health of the hotel he also appears to
have concealed potential conflicts of
interest stemming not just from his
ownership of this failing business but
also from his roles as the hotel's
lender and guarantor of its third-party
loans
while in office trump received
preferential treatment potentially worth
millions from a foreign bank it is
deutsche bank deutsche bank is endlessly
involved every single time there's a new
report about these conflicts deutsche
bank is involved trump did not publicly
disclose the benefits he got
um that it's a deferral that he got the
trump hotel received over 3.7 million
dollars from foreign governments
we knew that foreign governments were
staying at trump's dc hotel specifically
to curry favor with him and to
ingratiate themselves with him we now
know it is to the tune of 3.7 million
dollars
that is about 7 400 nights at trump
hotel at the average daily rate trump
didn't disclose that to the gsa
and he donated to the treasury only a
small portion of those payments
um and then it goes on and on a funny
business with the lease related to the
old post office building
and much much more
uh this is more of the same stuff that
he's been doing and getting away with
for his whole career he has bragged
about it he says he knows how to work
the system
uh he knows how to
uh essentially ignore regulations and
laws and we knew he was doing it on day
one where he showed up with the big
stack of paper and said here's the
paperwork that my attorneys are filing
in order to deal with my conflicts of
interest and we were like are the are
first of all are is the stack even of
is are they blank papers was there was
question one and number two are they
substantively meaningful in terms of
actually dealing with conflicts of
interest and uh it obviously they were
not um this should all be investigated
as many of these seem violations of the
for foreign corrupt practices act which
says it's unlawful for a u.s person or
company
um to offer pay or promise to pay money
or anything of value to foreign
officials for the purposes of obtaining
or retaining business
uh this seems to have been violated two
ways back and forth for lack of a better
term um this is it it's it's
the frustrating part is
obviously this was going on obviously it
was going on and now it could take as
we've been predicting for the better
part of this year already
it could take years to unwind and
uncover everything that went on
and we probably won't ever really learn
the full extent of it so incredible
revelations here and we'll continue to
follow them one of our sponsors is
privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance i love using free trials
because i know i won't be charged when
the trial is over if i use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a 25 a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create 60
card numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
pacman